good morning Dancing with the Stars fans
I'm Lauren Zima I'm Cameron Mathison and
look who we are here with Adam and Jenna
yes thanks for joining us good to see
you guys I don't know if we you were the
team I was like we have to have them in
here
you guys have team chemistry like nobody
else on the show right now how did you
get so closest partners I don't know I
think like originally it just happened
yeah I think right away we just started
joking and laughing and we've had such a
good time in every single rehearsal
actually we were parking like just here
yeah and Jenna was like you have to come
over to my place and she's and I was
like why are you telling me like I have
been avoiding well we have no time right
now but we're about to by the way that
doesn't always happen between pro dancer
and in celebrity so this is very nice
yeah sometimes a little tense they even
drove here together not everybody does
that yeah by the way you guys of course
we have a million questions for Adam and
Jenna if you're just tuning in to et
live we want your questions and comments
too so leave them on Twitter on Facebook
everywhere that you can and we will get
them and on our et iPad and ask this
lovely pair who drove here together I
love it cuz you live in LA I do how long
have you lived in LA now um almost five
years oh my gosh so it's like Fame is
nothing new to Adam rip on you guys but
this year's been crazy for you for a guy
for a guy who's been bounced around the
country traveling like non-stop and the
package on the show last night you
talked about getting about 3 hours of
sleep every night yes
lastly are you getting some sleep I got
four and a half hours last night you got
four to half I did yeah no wait a minute
why did you did you take him to
rehearsal no I think he would've got
some dinner with some friends which he
should do
like yeah yeah and so I actually live
like out on the west side so it takes me
I have to clarify LA he lives in
Manhattan Beach it's right I love it
there
well yeah so like it's it's easy for me
so when I was training it was easier for
me to get to the rink because there's
one right now Segundo and then there's
another really big training center where
I train full-time out in Long Beach
mm-hm so it was really easy for me to
stay near the airport to stay close to
Hollywood but now I've been like going
up to Hollywood every day and I'm just
like alright time to pack a lunch get in
the car for five hours a journey life is
a journey every day is an adventure you
know it add you how do you do this
journey only getting four hours of sleep
a night truly and your body is taking so
much because you're doing the skating
with the Stars tour you're doing Dancing
with the Stars how are you getting
through everything you're going through
on this journey well it's a few gummy
worms because he knows well you could
basically just eat whatever you want
non-stop here's the thing I keep telling
everybody that my body is just turning
into play-doh and then I will look in
the mirror and I'll just be like because
you're non-stop active you're you're
dead I mean this is as active as you are
obviously as a skater he told me at the
beginning he was like you know what I'm
so tired but I think if I take a day off
it will hit me and I'll be even more
exhausted and so I think our coolest no
day off yeah is that your trick you just
keep pushing through and yeah and you
know what I think I realized that you
know to be on tour with stars on ice and
doing Dancing with the Stars it's
exhausting but I don't think I'll ever
be this crazy with traveling I mean
hopefully I hope that my schedule is
crazy for the rest of my life it's
awesome
but I think that every rehearsal we go
into every show that I like get ready to
skate in I remind myself that I'm really
lucky to be doing what I'm do
and I need to enjoy it because I know
that if I wasn't doing it I'd be at home
literally willing to give up anything to
be a part of it everything that you've
accomplished everything this this this
wave that you're writing which has been
fantastic you really do seem super
grounded super you know deserving man
yeah I heard you on Ellen and you said
that you know your life has changed but
at your core you know who you are
same guy and your words same hot mess
yeah we don't see that underneath this
it's a fire well okay we saw in the
package again you and Mirai together on
this plane you've been going through
this whole thing together I mean do you
guys boost each other up in these
moments like hey you can't be tired we
got to get through this you know what do
you do for each other
well actually the day before we had this
show we were in Minneapolis and Mariah
came into a locker room that I was
sitting in and she came in she's just
started telling me she's like I'm so
tired and blah blah blah and sobbing
bawling and she's like I don't know how
I just enjoy it let's get into life
today is Chipotle I was like no that's
normal
like we all look forward to Chipotle I
like dumber I said she said something
last night like I'm just a valley girl
trying to do and I read that help to me
I'm like oh yeah at her heart she is
it's like she's this polished figure
skater but she's a valley girl yeah and
I guess I was like the wrong valley
cause she's from the San Gabriel Valley
which I love also want to ask you guys
about really getting in the Ellie I
don't mean that Beach the ice rink I
know what I started talking about we
could talk about that about three to
five years here at all room yeah you go
over the top of the leaderboard is that
let's talk about it because you and
Mariah
I think tied last night your performance
last night Cameron was there
you guys right after you guys were
unbelievable that quickstep like in the
words of lenss so much content how much
fun was that for you and how much of a
relief is it when you complete it
successfully and get those scores you
know this I think was by far the hardest
dance for us
so cha-cha came really easy but quick
step is very difficult it's just a lot
of structure a lot of technique and also
much weirdness like there's a lot of
life like I didn't get the quick step
when I did it just was like this weird
hopping around kicking but then he was
like maintain frame and I don't know
strange one I thought we were gonna have
a meltdown we had a few and there was
one day we were practicing like in a
hotel lobby at 6 a.m. we only had an
hour and a half before I didn't see him
until the show day but we did it and
it's so crazy like I think and I was
nervous that I gave him too much content
and then when Len said that he
appreciated how much there was I was
like it's all worthless Jenna I feel
like you also and just watching you this
season you are really coming into your
own as a pro and I would guess having a
great partner like really nice to have a
partner yeah a good teacher and she
explains things so well and she makes it
really fun I think that she's like such
a brilliant choreographer but she's more
than that like such a good teacher
I really enjoy teaching and it's it's
amazing to see your product go from day
one to day 7 and on show day he always
lights up and looks like you can't drop
this and like maybe afford at night you
have to come out every night and have it
well you got a 10:00 last night I mean
is that a little crazy Jenna a week
hello but then we're also like halfway
point semi-finals and so you gotta just
in your husband you told me last night
something on lines on the red carpet
that basically like this is the first
time that you've had a partner where you
don't really have to hold back with your
choreography you can literally just kind
of put in whatever you want to do and
you know who's gonna actually and it's
so exciting because you know I think as
choreographers and on the show we have
so many ideas but lots of times you
can't really do your full potential and
with him I'm just like what magic can we
create this week it's so exciting every
week I'm like
is the best I want to talk about Adams
unbelievable suit I know how much are
you loving these moments you're getting
to have and Dancing with the Stars with
a costume department no I love more than
anything a moment and I mean the costume
designers at Dancing with the Stars are
so awesome and I've fallen in love with
them yeah but Jenna has a really big say
in what everything like we put out there
I basically told him that I wanted us to
look like we're on fire you know very
bougie high and way so this is what they
came up with and I wish you could see
the detailing on my dress it's all like
orange and red fire and then his sue is
ridiculous Adam what words would you use
to describe that look in that moment
you're having last night I can't wait
for those words I know I you guys also
talked to Cameron about the Met Gala
last night you waited in a little on
those looks I have to say I want to pull
up a photo from actually week one Adam
you were giving Matt gala before Katy
Perry was giving him a gala with these
wings you know what I've heard that
before
I'm always giving Met Gala by the way
that's a good thing to hear yeah the
Oscars of fashion if you're hearing that
you're doing something right I maybe
took a note from Adam on this one yeah
she was like what I'm gonna wear the
screen go get yourself Oh have you had a
chance to look at the other looks from
last night is Rihanna still on top for
you guys are you - well I go ahead and
no ladies first
zendaya stolen for me I thought she
looked epic
she was like wearing armor but oh I know
like some Joan of Arc yeah well I loved
well because I love Jeremy Scott working
the look while pregnant is unbelievable
Jeremy dressing for two for two he had
two looks at the met Kathy yeah um
comments coming in from you guys
Shannon on Facebook of course is asking
what we can expect for next week what
dances do you guys have
oh and Shannon has a note she says I
would love to see maybe a slower
and I want to see Adams softer side
that's coming from Shanna we are not
allowed to say what we have yet no no
all right but you but I think Shannon's
going to be excited so Cameron did the
show so he knows them all so no I mean I
could be a robot no no Adam you are this
person who you're so fun you're always
having moments and saying these very
quotable things but are you wanting to
show like that softer or more emotional
side of you is that something we're
gonna see on the show yeah and you know
what I don't feel that it's something
that I hide or shy away from but I think
that like in so many different instances
in my life that I've always used humor
as a coping mechanism and that sometimes
instead of like really getting to the
nitty-gritty I've always sort of just
cracked a joke at myself it's easier to
call yourself trash than to tell someone
how you're actually feeling positive
outlook on life in general she's always
the light in the room and so I think
it'll be awesome for people to get to
know a different more vulnerable side of
him yeah I love hearing that though
because man you are this person who so
many people look up to but you've worked
so hard to get where you are so you had
to have those moments where you're like
I got to talk myself up especially with
the Olympics and all those ups and downs
yeah what's a pep talk that you give
yourself well I think that I'm able to
give myself a pep talk now because I
trust myself and I believe in myself and
it took me getting to a really like
rock-bottom place where I had nothing to
lose and I think that the most
successful and dangerous people
are people who have nothing to lose and
when I was at that place that's sort of
when I broke free because I wasn't
afraid of making mistakes I wasn't
afraid of just being myself and I
remember that and I take that with me
into every single thing that I do
because I know what it's like to kind of
always be wondering what other people
are thinking but when you're at that
place and you have nothing to lose it's
the best place to be so I always try to
enter every single situation I'm like
I lose just enjoy beautiful way to
transform obviously something very
difficult into something very powerful
and transform my way yeah I know I was
that before if that had to be like with
the Olympic stuff is that when you hit
that foot oh yeah I mean I didn't
qualify in 2010 but I was young and I
was like I'll do it next time
and then four years later I didn't do it
and that's where it felt like rock
bottom I was 24 which now I'm like what
a baby but it felt really old at the
time skating ad world that world it's
you know in that world that's like peak
you should be at your peak and I'm like
well I just didn't qualify when it's I
should have been at the best shape of my
life
and then when I got to that place that's
sort of when I changed my whole outlook
where I wasn't trying to go to the
Olympics coz if I wanted to just go to
the Olympics I could just buy a ticket
but I wanted to like better myself
so I changed what my goals and what my
outlook was and when I was able to do
that then I went into the rink and I
just enjoyed being an athlete and I
enjoyed pushing myself and now being on
the show that's what I enjoy the most
like it's so awesome to get tens and to
have that experience after but it's the
every day we're like we get to go into
the studio and I feel like I become like
a better version of me because I'm
pushing myself I'm stepping out of the
box with you and Mariah I mean like do
you guys do you feel like you pushed
yourself while you push each other I
should say well they both didn't make
the Olympics
yes exactly I was just thinking that
back in 2014 yeah Woolmer I made the
team in 2010 okay and then in 2014 we
both did make it right but when I moved
out to California five years ago I
didn't live in LA I lived in Lake
Arrowhead beautiful no on paper and so I
would go and visit her because she lives
in the wrong Valley mmm San Gabriel but
that's also where I live really I'm here
not quite
I live in Pasadena which is sort of
yes yeah so she was really close to
where I was living it's like 45 minutes
and so I would stay with her all the
time and so when we both didn't make it
we literally relied on each other to
kind of get through that time no I love
that well you know you and Mariah just
might be in the finals for Dancing with
the Stars that's how it's looking you
guys tied last night killing it so much
that would be so awesome pretty cool I
mean obviously you don't have a lot of
opportunity where you guys are going I
head-to-head against each other like
something like this
I mean I think I would be fine with it
I would love to see what more I would
say she seems I interviewed her at her
so Mirai seems she's competitive but she
did not like when she got that seven
she's like no I'm getting higher scores
what she done did but she's she's
focused and I lost them I tried to get
her some like to look in the camera and
give some fighting words to you like
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jenna I don't want to shock you but
we're getting a lot of questions people
asked including including Rosa from
YouTube we've seen Vallon the audience a
couple times has he helped with the
choreography at all or does he give you
notes what's he like is a boyfriend
watching you perform you know it's been
really rough because in the past we've
been able to help each other with
choreography but he's on tour right now
with his brother max so um I've had to
try to do the choreography in my head by
myself but he's flown in a few times and
helped Adam just with some guy stuff and
it's been an incredibly helpful I think
just seeing another guy do position boy
stuff but and just how to manhandle me I
think it like clicks for him seeing it
so yeah Val can manhandle me so yeah it
works I love it I let him hang there
every time Val is like he's like Cooper
I'm like okay all right geez Wow he's a
woman does he text you after your
performance is he able to so he's flown
in for both of the show so far my little
sweetie he was there last night in the
audience but he's had day Monday's off
so far so he's flown in I know he's so
sweet but yeah he texts me almost every
day and
you send him videos so he can give me
some notes or just see what's going on
it's so sweet I think he's like very
invested in it and it makes my heart one
first so I have to say it's been fun
just as a fan and know you guys a little
bit to watch you know and Val has said
that I think seeing Max and Peeta settle
down and being with you at that same
time it seems like you guys have gotten
to this really great and I mean pretty
serious please times a-tickin does that
mean a little a little time before the
ring-tailed see we both have very very
big things and busy things happening
right now so we'll let that right over
and that's what things they just keep
coming I know
[Applause]
I hope this right now I'll be like
listen
yeah but you I mean you don't light up
when you're talking about him he's the
guy for you you're so happy yeah so so
happy what is it about him that makes
you know is it like being in that world
together where you understand each
others worlds what is it you know I
think we've had lots of ups and downs
and I think we've had to go through a
lot of different things in life together
and apart and I think we just kind of
realized we're way better together and
yeah and then we got a dog and it's like
it's around now she's our child and
she's the cutest thing yeah she's like
this big I know we're like a little
obsessed
do you think it's harder weird for Val
to watch the show but not especially in
the audience but not be up there how
does he react to that you know I think
he does miss it he does I think he does
I mean he's been a part of it for I
think it's like 14 seasons now and so
this is a big transition but I'm gonna
this is gonna be mean but I'm like babe
it's okay now you just didn't want to
lose to your girlfriend do you think
he'd be back we have Sasha and Emma
together this season could we see you
and Val both as pros I would love to go
head-to-head with himself
oh well anyone asked you Adam because I
mean you're sleeping lean this great
relationship - he's moving to LA is this
pretty serious with you and your boy oh
yeah he's looking to move out here but
you know what was so nice is that like
we talked before all of the Olympic
stuff and and we've really got to know
each other before all of like the
craziness and he's one of the nicest
people I've ever met he's so sweet so
you were kind of Prince Harry Meagan
Markell and keeping things on the
down-low
yeah I'm like coming out everyone calls
me Megan I just have to share something
about JP so he is in Finland and he
wants to be here so bad but he messaged
me when we were having like a rough week
traveling a bunch he's like I need your
help well you get Adam our favorite
flowers please I just really want to be
there it was just so cute like there ah
JP is sweet it was really sweet didn't
he wrote her a message that like ice I
don't know any Finnish
but I know like a few sentences that
like you know when you're like dating
somebody you know when you're dating
some before and I know like oh you're
cute or like I love you or whatever so
like he wrote those to Jenna and she
wrote the card out and I think I was
really tired and I was like you
literally transcribed it for me yeah
okay how do you say you're cute in
Finnish
what was the thing they u0i how do you
see her cute Oh eat me Hana Hana mm-hmm
isn't it cute it's really like a
beautiful language and then I love you
is minotaur Custance you know what so
you've been saying that yeah getting you
to do things on the spot yeah you know
performing monkey here we say we silent
exactly we saw the pictures of you when
you're traveling stars and ice you're
performing me but you said one of the
most draining aspects of it is the
meet-and-greet because you want to be
present you want to be there you want to
make everybody's experience really
special and then there was the pose and
we saw that like pose you know group
after group you have this like pose down
and I'd like what's the post boat okay
the sono pose so you know like it's easy
to go through all of this and you know
my way of getting through all of all of
the performances is that I literally
like check out and I let go to the
locker room and I just kind of sit and I
just like save on my energy and then
when you have the mean greet after the
show you want to be present you want to
have this great experience with every
single person you met they watch the
show they want to share their experience
coming for you yes and so I found that
even if I'm really tired and might have
busted show makeup on I still could make
it look like a good picture if there's a
few guidelines one I always try to get
my left side because that's a good sign
yeah because the right side is where all
the fat goes let me see the bright
profile this is my good one okay yes all
I gotta know your sides they let this
thing mushy
okay so you go for the left side oh yeah
what's the next step then so well like
now if we're in a situation where like
we have Jenna on on the left
so don't angle my face I have to go full
on likes full straight and I put my head
into the head so there's a little touch
yes and no matter no matter how tired
you are if you don't smile with teeth no
teeth
it looks refreshed so yeah see I can
only smell it with teeth if I'm feeling
that really where were paym from okay we
have two I have two really good stories
one every time before we go out to
perform Jenna and I walk through the
dance while they're playing the package
and he forgets all of it every time this
is happened with bull shows you just
blink they're like alright you have two
minutes and we're like trying to go
through it and just blanks or does the
completely wrong stuff so I'm like what
a great performance and I'm like and
right before you go yeah and I'm like
last night it happened the night before
at the moment no it's on stage it
happens when were no because we go back
there and we like warm up the dance okay
fine yeah and then we go out to the
stage and she's like okay get into frame
I'm like the first thing goes I'm fine
and then I was like good luck four three
two the second story is Merv yeah so we
had our first camera blocking and it was
the day of the first show the premiere
and Jonas like just enjoy and perform
and I was like okay and so I was like
just put on a face and I was tired so I
was like I'm gonna put on my like my
best face my picture face so it's just
like okay and I did the whole day I was
like what is this face and so this is
the reporter you notice it in real time
no this isn't the replayed dress
rehearsal and I was I guess you ever do
this face ever yeah I was like well what
faces then we did it one more time and I
did the whole thing the next thing and I
was like it's not better
well then Gleb was performing with a
reek a and Gleb went out there and he
was like and I was like should I just do
that and she's like yes just like the
roof is that so
photos but just not video got it yeah
it's so like a little cuter in still
photos when you're trying to dance and
look sexy and you just do this Nomar
know so it's about it's Nomar it's it's
its tongue and smile doesn't Wow yeah
I'm not a performer in the context that
you are but what I did dance monsters a
long time ago my facial expressions
we're hard for me to like because your
word yeah my concentration and your
stress and it wasn't like the paso doble
that you're now all of a sudden I could
just yeah and then the room became after
that no yeah so but it's so hard to get
into cuz like but you realize when you
watch the pros and that's what I love
about the show you got to watch the pros
do it and you don't notice the facial
expressions you notice when someone
isn't doing or when somebody's out there
and they're just like burping oh yeah I
get it
like it's it always has to be alive yeah
by the way getting comments people are
disappointed that you are taken out of
there they just all want you i well
we're excited for I mean he's moving
here to LA it seems like you guys are
super happy and that's big that's a big
wait was he moving in LA before yes oh
that's actually so we must shunt in der
did I tell this story already we talked
about this no not today we're at well
okay so we matched on tinder
while I was at a competition in Finland
and I mean I was like I'm never gonna
meet him again so we when we started
talking he initially started chatting
because he was like oh I'm like moving
out to California and and I'm like how I
lived there and so that's how it all
started so it's like
unrelated a great bonus he sounds
awesome I was like each other
long distance in between California and
Finland yeah honestly like a
long-distance relationship here in LA is
like if you live in drag they're real
Valley oh my god I know but how often do
we get to see Facebook actually said has
tinder reached out to you about this you
need to be the face of the bride have to
ship things I wanna talk about back to
the answer with the stars the
competition your your fellow athletes
competing let's go through some of it
we've talked about Mariah of course who
killed it you guys top of the
leaderboard who else did you think did a
nice job who stood out for you I have to
say that I think that I there were a few
really awesome moments it was great for
Chris to get the first nine of the
season I was shocked at they're in the
bottom as well I thought their first
week was awesome and I also thought last
night was great too yeah up there in the
bottom um one of my other favorite
moments was Josh jumping over Sharna and
week one yeah I thought Kareem and
Lindsay last night that was my favorite
dance was Arnold is just he's so
creative she did such a great job with
him and about how incredibly yeah Haley
you know that's gotta be I respect troop
so much I mean I was on it for a lot of
seasons and you do a lot that people
don't get a recognize as much and you're
always down to do whatever to help
anyone out and so good for Haley for
being a team player and saying Lindsey's
hit on my shoulders and I'm gonna salsa
cream oh my gosh I was like folded
basically a ream go he just was so
lovely and seemed so into and trying so
hard literally last night when we
watched his dance he's like creams gonna
win creams doing this well I mean like
that um performance is so brilliant
links he's so smart so smart are you
guys feeling before the season started
so much of the talk was the figure
skaters always killed if killed in the
past on this show are you feeling like
it could be in
you Mirai Tonya is it feeling like that
could be the final that we see you know
football players always do really well
in the show too so just I think women
love them and they have such good
personality and they're like I didn't
like last night Josh in the passo like
yeah it was like he owns the floor this
masculinity about yeah Adam have you
interacted with Tonya much because you
and Mariah are so close but Tonya also
is a figure skater if you guys talked or
chatted at all not too much you know
Mariah and I are traveling a lot right
now so we don't get to really interact
with many of the athletes we were really
lucky to get to know a reek a pretty
well and to get to know Jenni because we
were on the same team this year this
year this year we're traveling but yeah
so we've spent a lot of time with like
our team yeah
and by that I mean 20 minutes but other
than that like Mariah and I we are like
almost so disconnected from the show
traveling so much well I got it I got to
ask you about this one because we had so
many comments coming in when people knew
that you're gonna come you gave an
interview and you said and I quote you
were asked if you're a team Tanya our
team Nancy and you said Tanya tried to
kill someone
so I'm team minutes yeah I mean does she
said anything to you about that she
heard you no no I mean you know what it
was a it was a long time ago and you
know I said that recently was a long
time ago yeah and you know what like I
think it's great that she's getting to
have a moment I think that I can't
imagine what it's like to be her and
have everybody just not want anything to
do with you and so I think it's really
nice that she gets to have a moment but
I think it's also important that we
remembered that like she was banned from
skating for a reason and it wasn't taken
away from her she was part of something
that wasn't good and that is that should
never happen again but at the same time
you know it's it's it's
all right because it's really nice to
see somebody being able to have a moment
and enjoy and really you can see that
she's really alive out there well being
so entrenched in the skating world how
does today's world of skating skaters
today how do they feel about the fact
that Tonya Harding is on this show in
getting this moment I think it's
conflicted because I think skaters today
a lot of the young ones are don't really
know the story but when when I grew up
when I started skating we we knew the
story and but because Tonya is banned we
never I've never met her before but
she's been nothing honestly she's been
nothing but kind to me and and very
sweet but you know you can tell she's
you know she's I think really living in
this moment right now she cries almost
every time we talk about the show and so
I can tell she's like really happy and
she's enjoying the experience a lot I
[Music]
guess do you think that people feel like
she should be getting this moment like
do you think that people in that world
feel it's deserved um I think that
there's some conflict because I think
maybe they don't feel that she should be
on the show or that we should be
celebrating somebody who did help or
knew of an attack of a competitor of
hers but you know even in the film even
though it's a dramatization of what her
life is you know that she had a really
rough upbringing and that she was
surrounded herself with really bad
people and stupid people but I think
that right now it's nice to see that she
has a moment but I think it's important
that we remember you know it wasn't she
wasn't taken away snuffing was taken
from her that she was part of something
that wasn't good but it happened many
years ago and you hope that people can
change you know so do you feel a little
conflicted on it a little bit but you
know what don't judge a book by its
trailer I go
and that's a moment with atom refund I
want you to show but you know what
honestly she's been she's so so
genuinely like yeah take a second good
time to practice our lean our photo I
mean we've said that before in our long
time but oh but it's coming out now you
said you are who you are you know I mean
he's here because he is I we have to
wrap with you guys but I do want to ask
but you know what love her or hate her
she got chased around by a bear
yesterday and she looked awesome that
bear that beard was on stage longer than
I thought that there was I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what when that's when
that started on hey Sasha he's a problem
I was thinking oh no I saw like the
campfire and he was creative with the
concept and I mean great honestly she's
been dancing great I know we were
nervous for like Tony has a quick sub -
we got up our game
ah well then who do you guys see in the
final who do you consider your absolute
biggest competition at this point
honestly it's in the fans hands well we
also just found out last night that
there's three couples eliminated this
week for a three couple final so we're a
little shocked and so I think it could
go any way yeah I'm not sure who's gonna
be there I think it's literally
dependent on the fans and what they want
to see so well we're hoping for the best
we wanna see I feel like three coppers
eliminated at this point I know it's
only it's you know gonna be 3/4 the way
through the season I feel like it's too
much I feel like I want you know four of
you to say well yes well we want to
finish up by asking you Adam you just
got announced your co-hosting The Trevor
Project Gala is that right that is so
amazing tell chase thank you no tell us
what that's gonna be like and you just
continue to do such important work well
you know it's it's really important
to kind of align myself and get involved
with causes and companies and people
that hold the same views that I do and
things that are important to me and
helping LGBTQ youth is something that's
really important to me it's also why I
work with glad and I'm really honored to
have been asked to host this dinner and
to be a part of helping up The Trevor
Project and I'm so looking forward to
the dinner I think it's gonna be great
we I just you you I don't know how you'd
find the time to do all these things
that's what a star well we got a rap
with this amazing team you guys but vote
vote vote for them as we just said three
couples eliminated next week the
competition is so intense but he's got a
ten last night they got a ten together
and we just hope to see more of you guys
so vote for them follow Adam and Jenna
on social media and watch Dancing with
the Stars Monday nights on ABC where our
own Cameron Mathison is there in the
room covering it his red carpet
interviews will be tonight on ET check
them out on e t online.com as well I I
got a knock out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]